dan seen or knows Brett Kavanaugh and
they both served in george w bush's
administration he's been talking to
Republican members of the House and
Senate dan good morning good morning
he's Cavanaugh gonna be confirmed I
think he will be I have never seen more
since Trump really has been elected I've
never seen more unity among Republicans
conservatives than right now so there is
a segment of the Republican electorate
that's either anti Trump or ambivalent
about Trump and those folks particularly
in suburban districts suburban
congressional districts and in certain
states there has always been this sense
of lack of enthusiasm among those
Republicans in other words they couldn't
distinguish between Donald Trump and the
Republican Party the whole thing was
chaos to them the whole thing was
frustrating to them and they didn't want
anything to do with it for the first
time in the last ten days
I think the Cavanaugh dynamic has
transformed that and brought all
Republicans regardless of what they
think of the president home Michael
barely lives in this world we have now
does that sustain that enthusiasm you're
talking about so it's so we got four
weeks let's just talk about that that's
a long time so so so if you look at
early in brown June if you look the
generic ballot in June Democrats had a
considerable advantage over Republicans
and then sorry
Republicans had tightened up with
Democrats and then over the summer you
had two things two big things happen you
had the child separation policy
implemented and you had Trump meeting
with Putin at Helsinki which was
politically disaster and then you saw
that generic ballot wide get wide open
so now it's narrowed again three polls
we've seen the enthusiasm gap in the
generic ballot gap to shrink it's four
weeks it's Trump you know he could
change he could inadvertently change to
the subject any moment and it would set
back Republicans but if the subject is
Cavanaugh the way Kavanaugh was treated
I think it is unifying and energizing
for Republicans there are eight states
eight states through the US Senate that
will determine the balance of the Senate
state eight states that are in place six
of those states there are more
Republican voters than Democratic voters
in those states so if people are amped
up in the next four weeks those states
will probably go red as somebody who
knows Brett Kavanaugh dan were you
surprised at how he plated the Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing because now
temperament has become an issue should
it be and were you surprised at the way
that he it should be considered in the
context so did he
little hot yes I everyone who raises
that charge I say to them if you had a
senior US Senator Dianne Feinstein
basically citing charges that were
orchestrated by Michael avenatti that
you led a gang rape charges that were
unverified uncorroborated I mean I said
everyone who like how would you respond
so he did get a little hot he's
acknowledged that he got a little hot
other Supreme Court justices have been
in temper at a times I think you have to
look at the totality of his career 300
opinions written twelve years on the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals he was you know
the ABA even the ABA which the president
called for an extended FBI investigation
the ABA still stood by their
recommendation that he was qualified and
had the right to ever say you have a
former supreme court justice saying that
because of his temperament he should not
be right and you had indicate in 2016
you had Ruth Bader Ginsburg giving an
interview in The New York Times openly
campaigning against Donald Trump and
saying she was gonna move to New Zealand
if he were elected I mean at times you
know the Supreme Court justices are
human and sometimes they say things that
are inappropriate or political or
intemperate I just think given all that
was going on this swirl what Brett
Kavanaugh did was not disqualifying and
that's why I think he'll get confirmed
dancing or will be watching thank you
good to see you